hi guys it's me quinn and as always if
you appreciate my content consider
hitting the like button it's the only
way the youtube algorithm really notices
me so i just saw the fourth episode of
apple tv's foundation which is based off
of isaac asimov's classic foundation
book series
this episode was definitely a mixed bag
and in my opinion it's been the weakest
episode of the entire season so far i
thought the plot was very tedious in
this one and this episode in particular
is the least like asimov's books of all
of the episodes that we've seen so far
as well now like in the previous episode
the scenes on trentor were the best
scenes one thing that we're definitely
starting to see in this episode is that
the emperors are different people
fundamentally they grow up in different
times they're
influenced by different things so just
naturally there's going to be
differences and it seems like the
youngest one the current brother don is
the most different perhaps of all of the
emperors that have come before him which
makes a lot of sense because he is
growing up in a very unique time harry's
selden's math is more or less undeniable
the empire is heading towards a collapse
and i think that all three of the
current emperors know this and it also
continues to be pretty obvious to me
that de mezro has some significant role
in everything that's going on here she's
definitely influencing the empires to
make different decisions and i wonder
how far exactly her plan stretches now
like i said this character does share
name with a character in the book but
the book character is in a totally
different incarnation than this
particular character um really the
circumstances surrounding how this
character appears in the book and how it
appears in the show are totally
different so i don't know to what degree
these characters will share
goals and motivation so all of that
remains to be seen another interesting
thing that this episode is introducing
is the fragmentation among the three
emperors they're not exactly cooperating
right now it was really interesting to
see the middle brother chastised the
younger brother for destroying the
planets thespis and enacrion in a
previous episode he points out that it
was reckless impulsive behavior and it's
caused way more problems than it
actually solved
now on that same line one of the most
famous lines in all of asimov's work is
violence is the last refuge of the
incompetent and this is a line that is
first said by mayor hardin i believe but
in the show
things are a bit different the most
important the most famous asimov line is
now just an old man thing according to
the tv show version of hardin this is
one of the changes that i really don't
get why is hardin someone in who in the
books says violence is the last refuge
of the incompetent so quick in the show
to grab a gun it's a change from the
books that at the moment i just don't
really understand but it could be an
opportunity for character development in
the future some other changes from the
book that showed up in this episode was
that harden seems to have mentality
abilities perhaps actually it almost is
certain that harden does have mentality
abilities in the show and basically
mentality abilities give you the ability
to read minds and manipulate people's
thoughts and their minds the problem
with metallic abilities is they kind of
throw off
psycho history psycho history has a hard
time predicting the future when the
variables of mentality abilities are
thrown in so it seems like somebody is
communicating with hardin from the
library on trantor and if you read the
books you know exactly well not exactly
but you have some idea of what's going
on here because there is a very specific
group
that is involved on trantor and i won't
spoil that for people that want to keep
watching the show to find out but there
is some book basis for like her seeing
someone on trantor if she is in fact
metallic which it looks like she
definitely is there was also a scene in
this show when she was flipping coins
and she was guessing the coin flip that
is not
in
the mentality abilities i don't think
from the book so that is like an extra
layer that they're putting on the show
that they somehow have these predictive
powers which i don't think is anywhere
in the books ultimately i found the plot
on terminus involving an acrion
and them trying to get past the fence
and them going to dig a tunnel i found
all of it extraordinarily tedious and
very
seen it all before
i wasn't particularly engaged throughout
any of it and that's sad to say i just
didn't find it particularly interesting
i thought the characters just all seem
pretty generic including the new
enactrion huntress that they've
introduced i just thought she's just
kind of a generic character that i've
seen in a bunch of other places before
harden has still not become any more
interesting to me unfortunately and none
of the other characters on terminus i'm
really care about at all either and
that's really a shame because if they're
going to make the pacing suffer so that
they can keep these characters around
and develop these characters they need
to give the characters traits and
identities that we can relate to and
actually care about when i watch the
character harden in this show i don't
really know what she cares about i don't
really know what her passions are i
don't really know what she even wants
out of life she's just kind of wandering
around reacting to things and to me
that's not a well-written character a
character should be more than just a
blank thing that's reacting to things
that are happening to them judging by
the pacing of the last two episodes my
hope of this show being a show based
around time jumps in any significant way
are kind of becoming a little bit dashed
because i can see them wanting to sit
with these characters and stu and these
specific characters and this to me feels
like it's going to be drawn out for
pretty much season long arc which at the
pace that it's going is not going to
hold my interest for very long now it
would be one thing if this show was like
more similar to the book and it really
was just about the formation of a new
galactic empire after the fall and it
included the time jumps in the manner
that the books did i would give this
show a little bit more leeway because
that's a more ambitious way of going
about doing things i think than trying
to appeal to a modern television
audience i think doing it the way asimov
did it and trying to adapt it that way
would be more ambitious so i would give
it a little bit more leeway for being
like weirdly paced in some areas but
because this show is trying to clearly
be something different there really is
no excuse for it to be as meandering as
it is and as generic as it is i don't
know how long the show is going to
continue to hold out on some of the
actually intriguing mysteries like what
exactly is the nature of the vault
because i know what the vault is in the
book but it's already significantly
different so it could be different in
the show
uh what is demezrel's role
in the shaping of the future of the
empire and also what's going on with
gail dornick uh who shows up again in
this episode right at the end and it
seems like there is some ship that's
there to receive her which obviously
implies this is all part of harry
selden's plan
him dying her being shot into outer
space in this uh cryosleep all of this
seems to be a part of harry selden's
plan
and i'm pretty sure that based on the
books i have an idea about where gail
dornick is ending up because she did
seem to display potential mentality
abilities it seemed like
um based on the way the show is
portraying metallic abilities so i am
definitely curious to see where that
aspect of the whole thing goes
because the fact that she's narrating
everything that's happening right now
kind of implies that she's gonna be
around
further into the future
and it also implies that she's gonna
somehow acquire
all of this knowledge so she needs to be
in a position where she's able to do so
my wishes for the next episode is that
they wrap up this terminus enacrion plot
and move on to something
a bit more
engaging and interesting and also my
hope is that we see more of gail dornick
in the next episode and learn more about
where she's going and learn more about
what happened to rach after harry
seldon's death and i just hope to get
more of a sense
of where this show is actually going on
the sense of like
scale because we cannot show the scale
of the formation of the empire if we're
going to stay
at this very constricted area of time on
terminus with all these little
characters for way too long this is not
what foundation is supposed to be about
we all understood that this show would
be significantly different from the
books but plenty of adaptations that are
different from the books they're based
off of are great stanley kubrick's the
shining based off of stephen king's book
for instance is really really different
from the actual book it's still a great
movie even though it took all those
liberties
i'm afraid that if the show continues
on this pace where it's going now and it
continues to show me the things that
i've seen in the last two episodes
specifically
then it's not gonna be very good in the
end
now things could definitely turn around
in the next episode but for right now
i am pretty worried
one of the highlights of this episode on
a side note was that the baron harkonnen
from the dune mini series showed up like
randomly and i'm like what is this guy
doing here so that was pretty cool and
also the emperor's shield thing like the
slow blade penetrates the shield was
very very taken straight out of tune i
should say so that was interesting
except for the game of thrones twist
it was like the dune gurney hallett paul
scene but with a game of thrones
littlefinger twist
alright guys thanks for listening i'll
see you in the next review for the next
episode thanks guys peace out